all right it has been hours since I last
asked you about your show The Bachelor
you know what happened in the car on the
way here did you talk to Peter or barb I
have exchanged texts with Peter today
and all I will say cuz I don't want to
give too much away because it's a really
personal conversation he's having a
tough time he's a little beat up
all his friends all his family everyone
that knows him knows it's not gonna work
I saw him immediately after the show and
I told you he's very upset
yeah he's a little bit you don't thrown
off by this whole thing and right now
he's concentrating on trying to put all
this back together his relationship with
Madison his relationship with his family
so I just said I love you I'm there if
you need me
you need a room and have you talked to
Barb no I absolutely not talked to Barb
or Peter senior I need some I think they
need a little time to reset to I would
like to they're my neighbors so as you
know I will run into him eventually and
by the way I have no love loss for
though I mean I'm not mad at Barban I'm
not even saying she's wrong I think the
timing is debatable but the delivery
yeah I mean look she means well I think
I know she loves Peter maybe this is the
push he needs to get out of the nest do
you think Peter season would have been
different if he wasn't someone who was
still living at home
good question I mean yeah cuz he'd be a
different person so yeah maybe fly Peter
fly out of that nest do we have a
million-in-one obstacles yeah is it all
uphill probably what is your advice to
Peter right now having been through what
he's been through my advice is this too
shall pass it doesn't feel like it and
I've been there I've been in these
storms when you're in the middle of that
tempest it feels like you're just being
swallowed up so yeah take a break
unplug get away and I promise this too
shall pass we did have the wildest
finale ever where will this go down for
you I just said ever but in your lexicon
of crazy ending is where's this one
gonna rank I would put that up over
there with Jason mesnick's moment this
was right up there as far as it was live
TV
there was no unplugging this there was
no unseeing this you had to live it and
I had to lean into it and deal with it
so it may be number one eventually it
might be there now who do you think from
Peters season will be the perfect
paradise contestants what
it's already there she's already there
yeah she's in her beginning she's
already on the beach waiting there's no
way with that coronavirus she is already
there she left last night I gotta see
the McKenna that Kelsey yeah I mean
McKenna
Kelsey Kelly I think would be great all
the Victoria's no I think there's a lot
there's a lot of these women I think
that would be really good
Tami you know what I thought about this
one more question from the finale all
the people in the room everybody was
having an emotional moment all the
players Peter Madison Peters senior who
do you think was having the most awkward
time who was thinking get me out of here
me right
I think me know Madison yeah when I
looked around the room again you can
feel energy I'm a big believer in that
and I wanted to give her a big hug I
just wanted to be like get out of here
and I thought at one point she might
just be like I'm done got ask you some
questions about your girl Claire we are
already seeing photos coming in
apparently she was filming in Sacramento
maybe people are wondering if her
ex-fiance benoît will be making an
appearance on The Bachelorette no new
chapter new page yeah flip the script
pues hey no but ya know we started
shooting like promotional stuff like
some stuff back in Sacramento hometown
stop I know she's doing a big photo
shoot today and then we get into
production pretty soon do you have any
off the bat frontrunners or knowing
Claire as well as you do a firmer past
on the show what kind of guy do you
think she needs she dates younger I know
people have talked about the age of
these guys but I'm just telling you
right now she's never dated a guy older
than her let's talk about your dreams
you went ahead and put a tropical rose'
in a can why is it the perfect drink for
the bachelor nation fan because my
girlfriend loves rose egg and I thought
why not dedicate my life to making her
happy no so when Seagram's escapes came
to me and they said hey we would love to
do a collaboration what kind of drink
and I said clearly simple but I wanted
it really light really refreshing and
under this sounds silly I wanted it to
taste awesome so I went to Chicago
myself hands-on created this drink
created the look of the can the flavors
the color everything about it and this
is my baby now
[Music]